Finally, we killed him today, guys. Nothing ever happens, Chud.
I want to kill him. Every time I see like whenever anything happens,
I think of his face. Whenever anything in the world starts to
happen, I see his face in my mind's eye and it's like, no, no,
not again. Where are you at on this? You think it was good that
Israel struck or not? How many people living Iran, by the way?
Yeah. I I don't know the population at all. No, I don't know
the population. You don't know the population of the country
you seek to topple? Wait, how many people living around? 92 million.
Okay. Yeah. How could you not know that? He asked the question.
Why wouldn't he know the answer? How legit are the conspiracy
theories about that Las Vegas shooting being related to the Saudis?
Uh, a million people tweeted this clip. Apparently Tucker Carlson
quizzing Mr. Ted Cruz. The Cruz missiles have never been down
this bad. Apparently Ted Cruz gets schooled on Israel right here.
Let's I don't know the population at all. No, I don't. The question
was what's the How many people live in Iran, by the way? Yeah.
I I don't know the population at all. No, I don't know the population.
You don't know the population of the country you seek to topple?
How many people living around? 92 million. Okay. Yeah. How could
you not know that? Wait, he asked the question. Why wouldn't
he know the answer? Wait, wait, wait. Yeah, of course he knows
the answer. Yeah, Ted Ted's not thinking in multiple dimensions.
Okay, I I don't sit around memorizing population tables. Well,
it's kind of relevant because you're calling for the overthrow
of the government. Why is it relevant whether it's 90 million
or 80 million or 100 million? Why is that? Because if you don't
know anything about the country, I didn't say I don't know anything
about the Okay. What's the ethnic mix of Oh, that's one you probably
should know. Actually,
why is this guy make Tuck Carlson look like a genius? What the
going on now? I'm going to I'm going to try to I'm going to try
to just get off the top of my dome. Okay. 73%
Persian.
Uh, no. 71%
Persian, 24%
Arab, and then other stuff smattered in. I'm going to go roughly
4:1 Persian to Arab. Okay. Iran demographics. I don't even understand.
Am I Am I
Tucker Carlson's intelligence or is Ted Cruz just so dumb? He
is Ted Cruz.
I can't see the actual Okay. Other sources such as Library give
Iran's ethnic groups as following. versions 65% Azarbaijani Turks
which are not in fact Arabs. I did not I did not realize the
Az Azarbaijani Turks were such a large group there but the Persianish
people are 66%. So about 70. I was a little low on the Persians.
They are Persians and predominantly Shia. Okay. No, you don't
know anything about Iran. So I
I could have said Persians. I could have said majority Persian
ethnic group. The the Tucker Carlson bird on Iran
who's calling the
about the country. No, you don't know anything about the country.
You're the one who claims they're not trying to murder Donald
Trump. You're the one who who can't figure out what what do you
find funny, Sherry. Do you think No. Well, I do think it's funny
cuz Tucker Collison is actually making a point here. I think
most people wouldn't know these stats, but if Ted Cruz is calling
for like the overthrow of this country, you would think you would
know these stats. You wouldn't just like, you know, out of ignorance
be calling for something like that. Well, it's not out of Well,
it's out of ignorance of Iran. He He just knows that the people
listen, he gets some money from some people who told him to have
a certain opinion, and he's going to have that opinion. Stop
asking questions. And it also really sucks to be uh Ted Cruz
and to be checking someone like, "Oh, do you do you understand
that they've been trying to uh attack our president Iran
because I'm sorry, but you are one of the people in that side
of the aisle that just doesn't trust government intelligence,
like doesn't trust our own government in when they tell us things
that happen." But now you're like, "Oh, Tucker, you don't believe
you don't believe our uh CIA FBI? That's you don't believe our
our government
CIA. They told us this." Yeah. Well, uh fun fact, also Tuck Carlson's
probably CIA agent. That's uh very funny for Ted. Also, I I do
think that Tucker agrees and believes that they have um Trump
threatening Trump's life. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. About the country.
No, you don't know anything about the country. You're the one
who claims they're not trying to murder Donald Trump. You're
the one who who can't figure out if General Solommani and you
said it was believe they're trying to murder Trump. Yes, I do.
Because you're not calling for military strikes against them
in retaliation. And if we are carrying out military strikes today,
you said Israel was right with our help.
Wait, what?
What is Ted What is Ted saying, dude? Ted, does Ted understand
that he's an American citizen? Show me the What flag does Ted
Cruz fly outside of his office? Ted, I said we Israel is leading
them, but we're supporting them. Well, this you're breaking news
here because the US government last night denied the National
Security Council spokesman Alex Fefeifer denied on behalf of
Trump that we were acting on Israel's behalf in any offensive
capacity. We're not bombing them. Israel's bombing them. Well,
you just said we were.
We are supporting Israelis. Thanks. You're a senator. If you're
saying the United States government is we're with Iran right
now, people are listening. O rough
rough stuff from Teddy Cruz. All right. Not good. That was just
a teaser of it. That was just a teaser. Yeah. They must have
they must have had a long talk. Jesus.
I actually don't know. And also Tucker. I grabbed another Tucker
thing. Was it Tucker and I think Tucker and Steve Bannon just
talked too about this topic. So there's lots of Israel stuff.
All kinds of Israel stuff. I believe we had comments about the
US joining the war. Israel's been saying the US will be joining
the war. Okay. Lots of people believing that the US will join
the war. Not anywhere near 100%. I got this article from earlier
today as well. Uh I I need to actually read through this because
this seems very concerning to me. Israel says Iran was racing
towards a nuclear weapon. US intel says it was years away.
That's so weird to be an American and Israel is the one who is
letting you know that you're going to be part of a war. I don't
like that order. No, it's not. It's not great. It's God. I I
don't know, man. I I think like I'm over here just I I think
I would prefer if even if just Trump tweeted to let me know that
that's what was going on. Why am I hearing it from Israel? What's
happening? Yeah. And not even not even Netanyahu, by the way.
Just random
like uh random like functionaries in the in the Israeli government
are just like, "Yeah, the US is helping us with this strike."
Right. It's like the assistant to the assistant of the department
of defense or something of the like minister of the department
of defense in Israel is like, "Yeah, no, the US is helping us."
It's like, "Bro, why does their entire government know that the
US is helping? Why do they all believe that 100%. The [__]
is going on?"
And then you find out that they're like flying more fueling equipment
over. They're flying more more bombers over. It's like, dude,
what is happen? Why does the random Why does like 50 the 50th
guy down the totem pole in Israel knows the US is going to help?
And the president of the United States is like, "No, no, they're
doing it on their own." Secretary of State literally puts out
a statement. Actually, we had no knowledge of this. Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
This whole time we thought Russia had a P tape, but actually
Israel has the P tape. It's something like that. Yeah. We don't
like Iran. Only mute. We don't like Iran. If you get elected,
okay, on a certain platform, you should probably actually not
lie about that platform. Wait, can you please don't do that?
Don't say we don't like. Cherry doesn't really know enough to
say who I like or don't like. Um, true. But I Cherry also knows
that when I'm referring to myself, I say we all the time. No,
you know that, but you understand the how that comes off to others.
Okay. Yeah. Pretty much anytime I've ever said we, it absolutely
does not mean cherry. But I Nobody No, don't do the don't do
the qualifiers. You have to learn how to speak in a way that
isn't like clippable.
Okay. I I can't even remember what I said, but yes, I I'll I'll
figure it out eventually. Eventually, we will understand.
Um, my bad. Anyway, to this back to this article right here,
which is about Israel and the US having difference of opinion
on how far Iran was away from a bomb. Remember, the entire pretense
for this war is that Iran was like weeks away from assembling
a bomb. When Israel launched its series of strikes against Iran
last week, it also issued a number of dire warnings with the
country's nuclear program, suggesting Iran was fast approaching
a point of no return in its quest to obtain nuclear weapons and
that the strikes were necessary to preempt the that outcome,
but US intelligence's assessments had reached a different conclusion.
Not only was Iran not actively pursuing a nuclear weapon, it
was also up to 3 years away from being able to produce and deliver
one to a target of its choosing, according to four people familiar
with the assessment. Another senior US official told the CNN
that Iran is about as close as you can get before building a
nuclear weapon. If Iran wanted one, they have all the things
they need. Now, after days of Israeli air strikes, US intelligence
officials believe that so far Israel may have set back Iran's
nuclear program by only a matter of months, according to one
of those people, a US official. Even as Israel has done significant
damage to Iran's facility at Natans, which houses centrifuges
necessary to enrich uranium, a second heavily fortified enrichment
site at Fordo, has remained effectively untouched. Israel lacks
the capability to damage Fordo without specific US weapons and
aerial support. Defense experts say Israel can hover over those
nuclear facilities, render them them inoperable, but if you really
want to dismantle them, it's either a US military strike or a
deal, said Brent Mcgherk, a former top diplomat to the Middle
East under Trump and Biden administrations and a CNN analyst.
That raises a key dilemma for the Trump administration, which
is struggling to avoid becoming entangled in a costly complex
war in the Middle East. Oh, not that one. Where's my classical
music? Well, I don't have it. So, we're back to this one. Back
to the date music, unfortunately. Although, President Trump,
can't you just get the music that I do like?
Yeah, I can. Hold on. Um, cuz I was trying to keep reading while
without interrupting myself, but here we go. I'll just start
from the beginning cuz I like the first song. First song's good.
There we go. Okay. Although President Donald Trump has made clear
that he does not want to involve the US in Israel's efforts to
destroy Iran's nuclear infrastructure, the administration recognizes
that the only way Israel can knock out Iran's nuclear program
is with American military assistance, sources told CNN over the
weekend. In particular, UF bombs capable of damaging underground
facilities and the B2 bombers that carry them. It's a tightroppe
that has led to debate amongst the more isolationist members
of the president's adviserss and some of Trump's more hawkish
Republican allies as well as some hedging from the president.
"We're not involved in it. It's possible we could get involved,
but we are not at this moment involved," Trump told ABC News
on Sunday morning. Trump speaking from the G7 summit in Canada
on Monday urged Israel and Iran to begin, "Well, I don't need
more of this to be honest. We've got all the background. I just
I'm more looking for um the stuff about Iran's nuclear program.
Same intelligence, different conclusions. US military intelligence
officials have long said that the US and Israel often differ
on how to interpret information on Iran's nuclear program, although
they closely share it. Trump's director of national intelligence,
Tulsi Gabbard, testified in March that the US intelligence community
continues to assess Iran is not building a nuclear weapon, and
Supreme Leader Kamani has not authorized a nuclear weapons program
that was uh that he suspended, sorry, not reauthorized a nuclear
weapons program that he suspended in 2003.
Oh, I am I am really not tapped in. She actually is director
of Yes, she was confirmed. Yes, she is director of national intelligence.
Yes, that
me. Yeah, your country's it's really hard to tell between her
and Pete Hegath. Who is the more awful appointee for one of those
cabinet positions?
Honestly, Pam Bondi as AG seems like a dream compared to those
two. Anyway, Gabbard insisted Tuesday that there's no daylight
between Trump's assessment and her pri prior characterization
that Iran was not building a nuclear weapon. Trump uh asked where
he personally stands on how close Iran was to getting a nuclear
weapon given what Gabber testified just months ago. Told reporters
on Air Force One early Tuesday, "Very close." And then Gabbert
came in and was like, "Well, we're not really saying something
different." No, you are. You are. One of them says, "Actually,
the Supreme Leader hasn't authorized a nuclear program and we
do not believe they're close to a nuclear weapon." And Trump
goes, "No, they're very close to a nuclear weapon." And Tulsi
goes, "President Trump was saying the same thing that I said
in my annual threat assessment back in March." No, he wasn't.
No, he wasn't. He totally undercut you. Totally cut your legs
out. Just like he did to Marco Rubio like 2 days ago when Rubio
comes out and says, "The US has no knowledge. No knowledge and
no is not does not support the strikes Israel has made into Iran."
And then Trump comes out like hours later and is like, "No, we
knew about it. We knew all about it." Yeah. No, we we knew about
it. We green lit it. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Our Secretary of Defense.
As I told you, my 2019 resolution is to say things on air that
I say off air. I don't think I've washed my hands for 10 years.
Really? I don't I don't really wash my hands. Help me. No, I
inoculate myself. This is not germs are not a real thing. I can't
see them. Therefore, they're not real. So, you're becoming immune.
That's your secretary of defense, Sherry. That's disgusting.
That's That's the guy in charge of helping Israel. Okay. Do you
think, Hold on. Do you think Israel can't get blackmail on this
guy? So, he advocates in favor of striking Iran. This guy is
the most blackmailable person on planet Earth. It's so It's actually
so God.
All right. No, not more Warren Smith. We read the intel reports.
God. Now, finally, it's that time, guys. It's It's really that
time. Okay. The time we've all been waiting for. We end on today's
show. Oh, never mind. No, it's time for Benny Boy Shabiro. He's
back.
Okay, but I was kind of close. You know when there's like always
like one hour left on stream, it's like I'm going to end now.
Don't worry, I'm not going to scam you guys. I'll bring the hour
to the next stream. I swear that's like a thing. Okay. Okay.
This is good, too. President Trump is threatening Iran. They
must, he says, unconditionally surrender. Tucker Carlson continues
to go nuts on Trump, who responds by calling Tucker cookie Tucker
Carlson. Plus, we get to the latest from the left and their bizarre
desire to crap on the military parade. First, if you think that
military parade was a joke, I'm sorry, Ben. Why is Ben Why is
Ben trying to defend the military parade? What are you doing?
Oh my goodness. Can I tell you? I watched the Daily Show and
they did that parade so dirty. They like zoomed in and like got
I don't know like a mic drop on one of the things and yeah they're
like oh that's bizarre. Why why are they all so squeaky? Tank
like rolls by and it's like it sounds like a it sounds like a
lame shopping cart at the grocery store. Okay, they could have
added the squeaking noise. I don't know. But it's just so petty
and funny I couldn't. Oh, it's pretty good stuff. Daily Wire
Plus is just a subscription to watch some shows. Think again.
The Daily Wire is building a home for people who have had enough.
Enough lies, enough rise with UNSAC. And when we fight, we win.
Join now at dailywireplus.com.
Wow. All righty. So, the news coming like a fire hose. A lot
of updates coming from the United States. What is the United
States going to do? But over the course of the last 24 hours,
Israel,
damn you, a 30 secondond Tommy C Easter egg, says Hellbent.
Cherry, are you ready? This one's going to be funny. It's going
to be a very funny one. Okay. Oh, it's from Hellbent. Hellbent
just sent this. 30 second Tommy C Easter egg. That is a move
file. So I cannot at this time play it. Hold on. Stop. What?
Nothing. I
don't know what that was going to be. Okay. Well, there's a streamable.
Daily Wire didn't go bankrupt yet. I think Jordan Peterson has
like a whole thing with Daily Wire. Have we had any major strikes
from Israel or
Iran? I know that there was a big strike in Tehran. I knew there
was some of that. And I heard that the MSAD headquarters got
hit. But if we had like a Has there been like a major escalation
anywhere? Cuz I have a feeling I know what clip I'm playing after
this. Okay. You could have called in there cuz I would let you
or anybody else. You could have. You blew it. No. Now you never
come in the server again. So sorry. You're going to have to go
suck their ass and pass their purity test and you can't come
around here. Yeah. You're going to pass a little purity test.
As soon as you walk off the reservation, they're going to eat
you alive. I've seen how clean works. I've seen how the rest
of them work. If if if if uh what the space doesn't make a video
uh exactly to uh and cover every base that we even wants and
it's a bad video or Jaw. I've seen that won't last. What I might
be gone, but they will be gone too. See you later. Bye. I feel
like the [__] you could handle. You can handle these
people. Okay. I think I defeated Queenman in a debate before.
All I had to do is Oh, so so and I just won. Oh, so soy. I don't
remember that. guy's never tried to debate me ever again since
then. I believe it. I don't know. He's like, "Where's the purity
test?" Dude, I'm like the easiest person to talk to in the world.
I don't even know what these people are talking about. I'm like
the I'm like the nicest easiest person to talk to in the world.
It's soed up this guy's like he tried to kill me. No, I don't
I don't get it. Also, where's the purity test? Like where I don't
Oh, he does fit cheese. Honestly, okay, one second. With that
whole Willie convo, the first thing I came on to talk about was
like, "Hey, I think your video would have been better if you
uh if you asked Destiny for some proof that any of the things
he said about Kelly were true." And he just had to totally concede
that. He just completely conceded that. I But honestly, like
that doesn't make his video awful. It's just like, "Oh, that
would have been good. I think that would have been good." God,
I whatever. I It doesn't even matter, bro. There's like there's
like 300 people tops who like have a differing opinion on this.
You Willie is making videos. He's doing fine. Nobody's having
problems. Everybody's having a great time. Where's the Where's
the issue? Everything is your fault. It's not It's not my fault.
But they just don't I don't know. They're just constantly going
to bring up like Kelly Jean. Oh, why didn't you talk to Kelly
Jean? Why'd you talk to Jog? It's so goofy. It's so goofy. Really
hates you. I know, but it's just goofy. It's Dude, I sit on here
all the time. We're streaming all the time. Just having discussions
all the time. It's never a big deal. You can be wrong on the
internet. That's okay. You can be wrong on the internet and not
die. It's It happens to everybody. It literally happens to everyone.
You can just be wrong on the internet and it's fine. Okay. Anyway,
back to Benny Boy. Thank you, Hellbent, for the Easter egg that
Tommy's got to bring me up again. I don't even What are we doing
till we get a creed? Yeah, but that's just people putting apes
in your chat and saying, "Why don't you talk to this guy? Why
don't you talk to that guy? Just ban them and move on." It's
so not confusing. Actually, I don't even understand what that
clip was or what the reaction is. I'm so lost. It's just uh Tommy
C like basically saying that I think he So, what it appears to
be is he must have banned from his Discord and then said, "We're
never going to talk and also as soon as you like don't follow
exactly what Queen or J tell you to do, they're going to like
you." Was what I got from that clip. I just don't think that's
real. Like I said, I'm so nice. The state of the commentary community
is me and JCO making the rounds sharking clout and testing purity
as we know. Yeah. Oh, were you around for that, Cherry? I think
you were. They like held that commentary community like state
state of the commentary community. And apparently they're talking.
I'm like, wait, what's going on? And then nobody nobody could
say anything. I'm like, hey, is there a problem? Everybody's
like, no, no problem. I Okay. Yeah, but it seems like they're
joking around, but then it's like you're looking for them to
have serious like you're looking for Aiden to have a serious
like criticism of you and he's just being a little Yeah, it was
Aiden that you were talking to. I remember
Aiden was in there. Yeah. Yeah. And he was just being a
But then you would engage like, "Oh, they're so scared to actually
say something about me. I wish they would just say something
about me, but they're just he's just being a looking for attention."
Oh, but it wasn't Aiden's face. It was the other guy who was
talking from before. I realize when Aiden when Aiden says something
like, "Re, he's just talking." That's totally fine. I was expecting
Aiden to have a serious negative opinion. It wasn't Aiden's face.
Okay. I actually I feel like I am too autistic for this. I can't
tell what's going on. Are you guys pretending that this is something?
Are we supposed to Is this like theater? Um, wait. The Tommy
thing. I feel like maybe we should talk about off stream. Never
mind. Okay. All right. Back to Ben Shapiro. told the Iranians
they were going to take their state media offline. They then
proceeded to do so in quite colorful fashion. The clip that was
making the rounds look like this.
Oh, Ben showing the uh the person whose studio came down on their
head.
In any case, what Israel is doing right now, they have complete
air superiority over the entire country of Iran. Not just that,
over the course of the last 24 hours, apparently they also took
down via a activist group, a group called Predatory Sparrow,
they took down Bank SEPA, which is one of Iran's oldest financial
institutions with ties to the IRGC as well as the army. According
to iron international.com, which is sort of a dissident website
that operates, I believe from outside Iran, several bank sepa
branches were closed on Tuesday as customers told Iran International
they were unable to access their accounts. They have 1,800 branches
in Iran and others in Britain, France, Germany, and Italy. The
United States imposed sanctions on Bank SPI in 2019. President
Trump did that after withdrew from Iran's 2015 nuclear deal.
So the banking system collapsing in Iran, the propaganda system
collapsing in Iran, and the military system collapsing in Iran
as well. According to Israel Hayom, Israeli Air Force jets struck
a man command center at the heart of Tehran, Ali Shadmani, that
is Iran's chief of war staff. He was the most senior operational
military commander in the country and the closest adviser to
Supreme Leader Ayatollah Ali Kame. I don't think I need most
of the actual catchup on Israel Iran. I think I'm just going
to skip to the Trump stuff. We've covered a bunch of the actual
facts of like what's happened over time. I don't even been recalling
everything that's happened so far. We can just move forward.
Delivered. So, what about President Trump? So, President Trump,
as I've been saying, is playing this absolutely brilliantly.
Thus far, the Israelis have basically done the world's dirty
work. The Israelis have taken out the vast majority of Iran's
ballistic missile launchers. They've now taken out Iran's top
military layer and many of the members of its secondary military
layer. They've taken out a vast bevy of maybe up to 90% of his
nuclear facilities. The only things that are really left on the
table for the Iranians right now are the Ayatollah himself, the
nuclear facility at Fordo and the oil fields. Those are really
the only things that Iran has. Israel has refrained from hitting
the oil fields specifically because it does not wish to create
any sort of serious oil spike. is refrained from hitting Kamei
because it would like to see Khame either surrender or flee presumably
because if Israel were to kamei then there's always the possibility
that there's some sort of red button somewhere that does let
off the rest of the missiles all at once and then there's the
Fordo nuclear facility. Now if Fordo goes down the problem for
Kamei is that that ends all nuclear future for the Ayatollas.
And at that point the regime is extraordinarily vulnerable. Obviously
militarily they're very vulnerable right now. They do not control
their skies. on the ground they're vulnerable as well because
Israel can hit them pretty much anywhere and when it come okay
that's the same thing because their skies are vulnerable comes
to its nuclear future the nuclear future was supposed to be the
guarantee that the Ayatollah could stay in power despite the
fact Iran drop is dropping nukes if USA is really involved
uh
that they're quite unpopular at home and this is wait can I you
understand you understand the entire purpose of that is uh the
entire entire purpose of all of this is that Iran does not have
a nuke, right? I just I hope you you've sort of missed the underlying
facts that have led to this entire thing happening. It's shocking
why the Ayatollah built Fordo below a mountain. Apparently they
they built the the main nuclear facilities at Fordo something
like 90 m deep encased in cement in order to prevent from exactly
the kind of Israeli air strikes that have been taking offline
nuclear facilities at Natans and Isvahan.
So the only people on planet earth who have the planes capable
of carrying the bunker busters that would make the process easy
are the Americans. Now, Israel, I'm sure, has come up with some
clever ways to take out Fordo or to wreck the inside of the facility.
Israel would not have entered this war without some end point.
I'm surprised that the US has never given Israel bunker busters.
I would have thought that like bunker busters would have been
kind of required to go and take out all of those
like tunnels and like I I I just kind of figured that they would
have them. It's a little weird that they don't. Weird. Uh I'm
just going to use the bathroom, get some more water. Be right
back. including the destruction of Fordo. It might be risky.
It might be costly, but there's no way the Israelis went into
this believing that there was no way they could take out Fordo.
With that said, everything becomes a lot easier for the world
if given the fact that Iran now has no offensive capabilities
to speak of. Again, they are firing one missile a night at the
Israelis and the Israelis are wrecking them militarily. The thing
that would end this war pretty quickly, and when I say pretty
quickly, I mean within 24 hours, is one B2 sorty from the United
States carrying a couple of bunker busters that drills for and
that's the end of the story. That's really the whole thing because
at that point, the Iranians have nothing to negotiate with. At
that point, Kamini has nothing to hold out for. He may as well
just say, "Listen, you guys got what you want. Please leave.
Please, please, please." And then it's just a question of whether
the people of Iran want to do anything. But nobody here, by the
way, is in the business of nation building. The United States
is not in the business of nation building. If you think Israel
is taking responsibility for nation building Iran, you got another
thing coming. Israel is a country of 9.7 million people. Iran
is a country of 91 million people located some 1500 miles away.
So none of that is happening. That is why all comparisons to
Iraq are just completely inapt here. They do not match at all.
This is much more similar to President Trump taking out Kasm
Solommani. A move celebrated by the way by many of the same people
who are now freaking out about the possibility of President Trump
taking out Foro. That is the reason why the latest polling shows
according to Grey House poll taken just a couple of days ago.
Do you support the United States attacking Iran if necessary
Trump voters? Yes. 72%. No. 19%.
That's a very very large majority. The idea that there's a giant
split in Trump's base over whether we should fly one B2 sorty
taking out Fordo if we have to if that's the best choice. Actually,
that is not particularly divisive inside the Republican party.
Which is why yesterday
or late yesterday evening, President Trump announced that he'd
be leaving the G7 summit early to return to Washington? Okay.
What's wrong with this guy?
How is that not just manufacturing consent? Yeah, if necessary,
could the could could the US strike Iran? Yeah, what does necessary
mean for the US? Like, of course, that's all built into the question.
Why don't we just look at the real situation right now? Is Iran
close to a nuclear weapon? Are they close to ca are they close
to the capability of striking Israel with that nuclear weapon?
No and no. No and no. Why would it be necessary to strike that
facility right now?
It's not. Anyway, DC and there was talk that he was going to
be meeting with the National Security Council inside the situation
room. Trump absolutely has a massive split in his base. There's
a lot of speculation that there may have been a military move
that was happening as of last night. According to Associated
Press, world leaders had gathered in Canada with the specific
goal of helping to diffuse a series of global pressure points
only to be disrupted by a showdown over Iran's nuclear program
that could escalate in dangerous and uncontrollable ways. Again,
I'm waiting to see an explanation for what the escalation looks
like. China is already abandoning ship. Russia has already abandoned
ship. They told Ayatini, "We are not coming to your rescue at
all. There are no outside forces coming to the rescue of Iran
at this point." So, the only question is what are Iran's capabilities?
And let's just put it this way. If Iran had significant offensive
capabilities, they should have flexed them already, considering
that Israel is completely wiping the Iranian military and nuclear
facil. Yeah, that's what I would assume as well. Actually, if
Iran had like significant capacity to do damage and if they had
significant intelligence, they would be hitting Israel pretty
hard right now and I don't think they're capable off the map
with extraordinary impunity right now. So, President Trump left
to head back to Washington. And President Trump was asked on
Air Force One about negotiating because, of course, there are
some in his administration who have been leaking to the press.
We can speculate who those people are. There are some who've
been leaking to the press. The President Trump is trying negotiations
and Trump's like, "Uh, no, I don't know." That's that's going
to be a no. Bennett Ben is so transparently in the tank for Israel.
It's like actually so funny to watch. He's just like, "What?
Guys, we have to strike. It's the best thing for us, guys. It's
the best thing. Come on, bro.
Why Why does it got to be like this? No. Fro me, dog. Are you
open to negotiating with the Iranians right now? Or do we want
to wait? I don't know. I I've been negotiating. I told them to
do the deal. They should have done the deal. The cities have
been blown to pieces. They lost a lot of people. They should
have done the deal. I told them do the deal. So, I don't know.
I'm not too much in a mood. Not in too much of a mood to negotiate.
Is one of the great historic clients. I got to say it's really
great. It's not just Dude,
dude, I wish you could I wish you could take that clip right
there and show it to Ben Shapiro from like 2015. Okay. Hey, did
you ever think Hey, Ben, I know that you just left Breitbart
with your editor-inchief. I know you just quit because Trump's
campaign manager barely touched your manager's arm or your sorry,
one of your one of your writer's arms. Okay, I know you think
Trump's like the most disgusting thing you've ever seen the Republican
party, but could you imagine you'd be licking his balls like
this in 8 years, 9 years? Ben, do you ever imagine you'd be blowing
Trump openly like this? It's It's a little gross. We're not negotiating
right now. I'm not in the mood to negotiate. Is just spectacular.
It's just spectacular. It's just great stuff. This is among many
other things what I voted for. This is what I voted for. I said
I voted for Trump 1.0 foreign policy. This is like Trump 1.0
on steroids. And it is great. This is what peace through strength
looks like. Because guess what? Iran's a hell of a lot less of
a threat to the region now than they were even a week ago. and
they will be a hell of a lot less of a threat a week from now
than they are even now. President Trump, meanwhile, was asked
about a ceasefire. There are a bunch of people at the G7 who
are calling for President Trump to broker a ceasefire. He's like,
"We're not doing ceasefires. Ceasefires are temporary. What I
want is an end to this war, like an end end, meaning no nuclear."
Uh, broadly, a lot of the conservative collectivists in the US
do not want war with Iran. Only you're thinking of like neocons.
Neocons don't even have a place in that party anymore. There's
there's a significant piece of that party that do not want to
go to war. Hello, who joined? Yo. Yo, what? What's up? How's
it going? Where are you at on this? You think it was good that
Israel struck or not? Um, is it good? Uh, it really just comes
down to so basically comes down to how much you know about Iran's
nuclear weapon progress, like their their nuclear program. And
we'll never know. We'll never know exactly where it was. There
was a report today where the US said they're years away from
a bomb. they're actually years away from bomb then no I don't
support uh Israel preemptively striking them. My understanding
was that the idea that was being the thing that I kept hearing
from uh I won't call them zogbots but you know the types of people
I mean
uh was that there's this report from I don't know they linked
to me some science institution that's talking about the purity
of uranium that they can get and that they've got enough they
can like um they've got the capacity to they recently ramped
up production or or
uh yeah yeah um and they could pump like a bunch in the next
few months.
But I the thing I heard when I watched the talk about it was
that there's more than just that and that their weapons program
hasn't been active for ages. So the chances that they could actually
spin something up that they could use soon is slim. And Tulsi
Gabbard testified in front of Congress in March, I think, that
basically Iran had not reactivated their weapons program at all.
Yeah. So that's the director of national intelligence. It just
I I I feel like I I watched Loner Box and I heard him say he
was leaning in favor of the strike based on intelligence he was
reading. What? Um why would he say that? I mean I think I think
Lonerbox would be in favor of I I don't think Lonerbox likes
the Axis of resistance. I think he really hates how Iran has
basically because they can't afford to build aircraft carriers
or any navy that they've basically decided to project power.
They're going to uh fund whatever like terrorist groups they
can around them and weaponize them like um give them technology,
give them missiles, give them any weapons they need, right? I
think he just really hates that what they've done to the region
overall in terms of destabilizing it. Is he not just like super
anti-war
peace kind of guy? Loter box. I don't know if he's a Is that
too simplistic?
Yeah, I don't I have never gotten that impression personally.
uh he doesn't like what Israel's done to Palestine, but I don't
think he's like a peacenick or something. But I could be wrong,
too. I've watched a decent amount of his content, though. I don't
I don't think I'm wrong on that. I don't think he's like, "No,
no, no. War is always bad." Yeah. That's like that, you know,
only a minority of people take. Yeah. Um I I would say I don't
even know if like is he more Well, it's always like bad, you
know, like it's always bad when people die, if you know what
I mean, but like ultimately sometimes just something has to happen.
Yeah. Yeah, owner box used to be claimed to be democratic socialist
adjacent if I recall correctly. Yeah, but lots of democratic
socialists could justify certain foreign policy, right? Yeah,
that's stupid complaint. I just I was just surprised cuz it just
seemed like, you know, everything I was hearing, it seemed like
there wasn't a great justification for this and
it seemed like Israel just kind of
whing out. Um, I think they basically have been like escalating
with Iran and trying to get Iran to attack them. And I think
Iran's kind of been holding back and going like, "No, we're going
to We don't want to do that." Actually, we don't want we don't
want like that. Actually, their initial missile attacks were
like super telegraphed and basically just being like, "Yeah,
here you can shoot those down if you want." Right. And I think
basically Israel got hit back this time after they went super
hard on Iran, right? They went they like um they got hit back
and some strikes actually hit Tel Aviv and they're just like
yeah no that's it. America get on it. America B2s now. Okay.
They hit a building in Tel Aviv. B2s now.
It's like I don't know. You kind of just like you kind of just
crippled like a bunch of their uh nuclear research. I don't know
if I don't know if B2s are appropriate right now. Yeah. But at
the same time it would Yeah, it depends on it basically depends
on how close they are to a nuclear weapon. I don't think there's
a lot of reason to believe they're that close or that much closer
than they were like a year ago or two years ago. So, yeah. Oh,
did you have you looked at um there's a Caspian report video
that basically like this is also the instant they could make
these attacks more or less. Well, like it wasn't the last available
opportunity. There's a first. Like this is the f this was like
literally because they actually because they rolled into Syria
and took over a couple places in Syria and they were able to
basically set a staging ground to take out all anti-air in Syria
because there's tons of like like relatively advanced not like
their best but relatively advanced Russian anti-air in Syria.
That would have made it a real nightmare to fly their uh their
refueling planes over Syria. Now that they've been able to take
all of that out, they can fly refueling planes over Syria, which
means they can fly right up to like the edge of Iraq and be refueling
their F-35s. Their F-35s can run a mission, hit Iran, and come
back and get refueled midair again, and they can actually strike.
So, they couldn't really hit Iran that effectively with their
aircraft because of all the anti-air that was in Syria because
Assad got toppled now. And because they've taken their own staging
grounds there and they've spent a bunch of time eliminating all
the anti-air in Syria, they can actually strike Iran effectively
now. And like it's not it's not like they just weren't doing
this before. They actually did not have the capability to do
these exact like precision
um like stealth missions. Yeah. So it's not it's not like the
whole pager thing where it's like it was now or never. It's like
this is the literally you've just cleared the way to be able
to do this and you're immediately doing it because this is clearly
what you want to do. Yeah. There was a five months ago there's
a Caspian report video that we watched on stream uh that basically
showed ba like as Assad fell it's like yeah Israel just checkmated
Iran. They're going to take out all the anti-air here and then
they'll have a free free reign over Iran and they can do whatever
they want and then it just happened. So yeah, as long as like
uh you know all these uh claims of urgency aren't actually that
urgent. Yeah, I think I think the US getting involved would be
a major mistake right now. I mean, no, I think it would be an
amazing choice. I I think Trump would completely tarnish any
form of legacy he thought he was going to have. I think MAGA
would be completely
uh I think it' be a great idea actually. I think that's a cleansing
moment for America. Okay. Getting involved in another war in
the Middle East. Oh, also did you see Klinsky posting all day
today just all of the tweets? Also, what did you just say, Cherry?
You're going to cut in there? It just doesn't seem like we have
a choice, right? It seems like Israel is like letting us know
that we're getting in this. They're letting Trump know. Yeah.
Uh, and the few senators that we have that are like supportive
of it, apparently they don't know. You should show them that
Ted Cruz clip. I watched the Ted R clip.
Ridiculous. Rough, dude. I can't believe T. That's like the one
Tucker W in like the last years. Our president will start a war
with Iran because he has absolutely no ability to negotiate.
He's weak and he's ineffective. Our god Kyle's just been posting
these like some Trump bangers from way back when when he was
like Obama's going to go to war with Iran. Uh the United States
has spent 8 trillion dollars fighting and policing in the Middle
East. Thousands of our great soldiers have died or been wounded.
Millions have pe of people have died on the other side. Going
to the Middle East is the worst decision ever made. Amazing.
Amazing.
Policy insight Trump. Thank you. Yeah. I some people think it's
like um the Iranians trying to Trump during the election that
there was like the FBI is basically Yeah, we know Iran like the
state of Iran basically ordered you during the election. I mean
they they had multiple cred like credible threats from Iran,
right? Yes. And then recently they were freaking out because
what is it? Comey thought he would be funny by posting the something
86 8647 and they're like and they're like
um we can't like we can't take anything as a joke. We have to
investigate everything like it's a serious threat. Like I I just
think that there are still threats coming to him and those things
getting popularized on Twitter I don't think like really helped.
Yeah. I and I think Trump does make a lot of like decisions based
on his personal feelings. I did think um I I don't know. I like
do you not do you not feel like this man's life has been under
threat for so long that he would just be like yeah yeah let me
start being a dictator. I thought this was a joke but apparently
he told JD Vance like if I do get killed and it's Iran that did
it like literally nuke them apparently. I thought it was a joke
but apparently he told JD like if I get killed by by Iran Yeah.
No. Uh like actually blow that country up. Okay. Uh where are
we going next? What a great choice. Yeah. Yeah. Not a great choice.
Oh, I'm not going to get to it. I was going to do some I was
going to watch some Asmin Gold commentary on this, but I'm not
actually going to make it to that today. Wow. I have not touched
that at all. I think I'm better off for it to be honest. I am
going to enjoy it cuz I I've watched enough I've like looked
enough into the region. I know enough that I feel like I could
actually point out how he's pretty effectively. Like you can
always do it, but I'm saying that like he there will be some
deeper points there that will be even more JD. If they kill me,
I need you to nuke the capital of a 90 million population country
when the leader 100% will not be there for it. Yeah, exactly.
Tourniquette, what was it? Did you see the tweet queen today
uh from the it was like some account was basically saying the
Shaw has gone not the Sha the Ayat supreme leader is like gone
underground and he's just let the IRGC they're like yeah he's
like you run the country now. Good luck. I'm hiding down here
with my family. Good luck guys. I saw there was the the Israeli
guys pos posing with the sh as well, right? Yes. Yeah, the Sha
has been putting out messages. I think I got a Shaw tweet right
here. Uh, sorry. The the son of the Sha, Raza Palavi, crown prince
of Iran and son of Sha Muhammad Resa Palavi of Iran, who depo
who's deposed from power in 1979, released a message earlier
today to the people of Iran, calling for an uprising against
the Islamic regime, stating, "The Islamic Republic has come to
an end and is falling. Now is the time to stand up, the time
to take Iran back. All of us together do not be preoccupied about
the day after the fall of the Islamic Republic. Iran will not
enter a period civil war or instability. We have a plan for Iran's
future. And then he's like sitting there shaking hands with a
bunch of dudes. I
do have a plan for Iran's future, guys.
I don't care to listen to this. But yeah, the son of the shaw
is making I saw these tweets that were like mocking the way Zionist
were talking about the uh Iran bombings where people were like
just spoke to just spoke to some of my friends from Israel. They
they were celebrating the strikes from Iran. They can't wait
to be free of the Zionist yoke. Um they they're dancing in the
streets and all this. It's just so funny. I I do wonder a little
bit how much uh cuz apparently like they they do have state propaganda.
I wonder how informed like the broad Iranian population is cuz
they understand the theat is not popular there necessarily that
I think that is like a 60% unfavorable view of the Islamic Republic
or whatever. So I I do understand there are like a lot there
is a lot of discontent with uh with the regime there but I don't
think that um generally people's reactions to having strikes
on their cities is um oh thank thank oh we can finally get rid
of our leaders. I think usually they're more like, "Dude, these
people are attacking us. What the [__] is wrong?"
Yeah, it's a good way to bring people together in solidarity.
I understand people don't like Kmeni. I understand they don't
like the Islamic Republic. I know that the population doesn't,
but I don't know how aware they are of like how they are. Do
you know what I mean? Yeah. Like I mean, even the American population
like which is theoretically a better educated population is have
no idea like about
even about the Iranian nuclear deal and that's been like a big
point in their politics. So like I mean Iranians aren't going
to have like a clue I don't think either. So well they I think
they have like a pretty young population and I do think they
have like a lot of like people online and I don't think they
have the technology like China does to really control. So they
might have like a reasonably large population that does have
some idea but I don't think they would be like politically effective
right they'd be young people who'd be like talking about it.
So, I don't know if that's like a threat to the shot outside
of times like this where there could be like some kind of counterrevolution.
Trump Trump saying Tyran should evacuate immediately with reallyed
up because they were already panicking and trying to get all
this packed and leave and Trump did that and made the traffic
jams on the highways out there even worse. Yeah, he did. That's
crazy. You're such a powerful The president of the United States
is so powerful that he's just like, "You need to evacuate that
country's capital." And they all flee. Everybody runs.
Yeah. No. I mean, we could have figured that out. Trump is like
the only person that didn't know that. That's Iran has eirls.
Do they? My president is like Kim Jong-un to this world. Um,
he's like Kim Jong-un, but if Kim Jong-un's like stated power
was much closer to what it actually is, like if he was actually
close to being like a demigod and could order whatever he wanted
to happen in the world, he's like he's like that. But he's just
as dumb. Okay. He's just as vain. He's just as dumb.
Am
I going to hear? Yeah. Yeah, that is what I'm going to hear.
I was like, am I going to hear air strikes? Yeah.
No, that's scary.
Jesus, she's actually like
Yeah, cuz there's [__] bombs outside our place. Yeah.
Shouldn't have supported as long shouldn't have supported a theocracy,
Jerry. Okay. Shut up. Shut. Don't. No. Stop. She's too beautiful
to die. Is that true?
She's not facing the camera. I can't tell. You're just mad. I
said it first. Okay. Okay. This weirdass truth social post tonight
at the security. Oh, the one. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I saw. Yeah,
I did see
Hold on. I'm going to go back to Ben for a little longer. What
specifically is better than a ceasefire? What are you paying
for here? An a real ant, not a ceasefire. And it is something
that will be permanent. Yeah. Or or uh giving up entirely. Is
that okay too? Are you closely or are you possible? Is that possible
next week? Why not? Certainly possible. Complete uh give up.
That's possible. You says give up. That's possible, right? That
seems like a pretty clear message. Again, he has played this
all the way. All the way to the mat. He's got all the cars. As
President Trump likes to say, he is the one with all of the cars.
I bro, it's like I don't want to do like uh conspiracy theories
or anything, but I feel like Ben's sitting here and he's just
like so overtly happy about Israel's manipulation of Trump working
so well. He like can't contain himself. He's just so psyched.
Trump has played this so well. He's got all the cars. He is so
per I for intense,
bro. Oh, by the way, no escalation today, right? Do we play the
video? I I sort of um my my intro was saying we might kill them
today, but I don't think we killed them. I don't think we killed
him today. Well, then nothing but nothing ever happens. I don't
think we killed him today, guys. Nothing ever happens, Chud.
I want to Every time I see like whenever anything happens, I
think of his face. Whenever anything in the world starts to happen,
I see his face in my mind's eye and it's like, "No, son of a
bitch." No, not again. Every time. Every time you're thinking
he will be defeated, it's like finally. Every time something
happens, you're like finally
you're going to die. You know this. Nothing ever happens. Ch
will lose.
And every time he's undefeated every time.
The arc of history is long, but it bends towards the nothing
ever happens chut. Show him the chud. I sent him the chud face
in DMs already.
Oh, where is it? Bro, that dude, did you see Supreme came on
and like tried to like prep us for what was going to happen in
the clip and then totally undersold like how he actually how
mean he was to Will? It was so good. I didn't I didn't hear any
of it. It was that genuinely some of the funniest that's ever
happened. That that that was like classic. It's so funny. So
funny every time you go back and watch it as well. It's like
so good. Oh, I'm glad, dude. I don't think we like knew each
other back then and I remember watching it live and just being
like this is I brought up to Supreme I think the first time I
talked to him. I'm like this is like one of my favorite moments
of all time and I'm like I I told Supreme I'm like this guy literally
screams about how every single person is including actual purported
rap victims. Okay. And he's so uncomfortable with what you just
did to Will. He's like he can't handle it. He's so uncomfortable.
You know Will apparently left immediately after that. Yeah. I
saw I watched your clip of it and I saw you say that then he
just walked out the doors was like you know what I can't do it.
I'm out. I'm out. Didn't say bye to anyone. Just left. Oh guy.
A dude. Supreme came on. Was literally sitting here. He was like
I was like hold on. We can watch it. I got the clip right now.
Are you sure you want to make a statement before we watch it?
He's like yeah. I totally told Will. I was like you got to go
but also bring somebody else up and go hang out with a Gappy
downstairs. Gappy's cool. And it's like then you watch it. He's
like, "Get the out of here." No, no, no. Don't. He It was literally
just There was nothing. He didn't He didn't give him anything
to recover with. He's like, "Go hang with Gappy or something."
He does say that, but it's like, you know, it's like Sorry, it
was um Yeah. Yeah. Sorry.
He didn't recall that he sent him to Gabby. Supreme
I think the way that he remembered it. Yeah, I recalled that.
But the way that Supreme remembered it was that uh he was trying
to like cycle out guests to come on the stream and
Will had been there for like 25 minutes already. So he like told
Will to, you know, this like enough go downstairs and send somebody
else up and yeah, that did not happen. Yeah, that's that's why
I watched that didn't happen. It was uh it was brutal. He did
say the thing, go yeah, go talk to Gabby. That's what Cherry
said. I think I think Cherry said that and he was like, no, I
don't think it quite went like Sorry. Also, Supreme just feels
bad that like that happened, but it is like super funny. Like
he shouldn't feel bad. It's just comedy now. Okay. Will Will
didn't kill himself. Will's fine. Okay. Will's okay. Fortunately.
Okay. And that's real. And so he's playing all of those cards.
He was asked about the fact that Tulsi Gabbard, his director
of national intelligence, who put out that bizarre video last
week that we analyzed, the one where she talked about the evils
of Hiroshima and Nagasaki and seemed to imply that any action
against Iran would somehow end a nuclear confilgration, even
though the whole goal of the Israeli operation is to prevent
Iran from getting nuclear weapons. None of it made any sense.
Tulsey Gabbard a few months ago had testified that there was
no ongoing nuclear threat from Iran. Of course, this is contradicted
by literally all intelligence services and the IAEA. President
Trump was asked about not contradicted by the United States.
Gabbard's comments. He's like, "Uh, no. That's a big no from
me." Mr. always said that you don't This is This is brutal. They're
literally like, "Hey, Tulsi Gabbard said Iran was not close to
a nuclear weapon like a couple months ago. Would you say that's
accurate?" And he was like, "No, I think they're pretty close."
Comments, he's like, "Uh, no. That's a big no for me. They've
always said that you don't believe Iran should be able to have
a nuclear weapon, but how close do you personally think that
they were to getting one? Because Tulsi Gab Tulsey Gabry testified
in March that that the intelligence community said Iran wasn't
building a nuclear weapon. I don't care what she said. I think
they were very close to happen.
Yep. Yep. Just director of national intelligence.
Nice knees you have. It'd be a shame if somebody just totally
cut those out. Okay.
You Tulsa. you. He is correct. She was a Democrat. Okay, we don't
trust her anyway.
And it does not sound like Tulsi Gabbard, our DNI, is in the
good graces of the president, nor should she be because that
was trash when she said it. It was silly. And it was contradicted
at the time by the Secretary of Defense, Pete Hexath. Okay, so
then the president decided to take to Truth Social and let his
thoughts be known. Quote, Iran should have signed the deal. I
told them to sign. What a shame and waste of human life. Simply
stated, Iran cannot have a nuclear weapon. I said it over and
over and over again. Everyone should immediately evacuate to
Iran. That is what he sent yesterday evening at 6:30 p.m. By
the way, when he says he said it over and over and over again,
he did say it over and over and over again. Steve guest cut a
16minute compilation of President Trump saying it over and over
and over again. Here's just a few seconds of it. You cannot let
Iran have a nuclear weapon. You cannot let it happen because
uh 2024. Notice how this is very different rhetoric from any
time before this. Bad things will happen if that happens. But
everybody stopped. They were ready to make a deal. We would have
made a deal that was great for everybody. No nuclear weapons.
You can't give them nuclear weapons. Now they could have a nuclear
weapon.
Don't let Iran
have nuclear weapons. That's my only thing I have to tell you
today. Don't let them have it. They would have never had them.
Including Iran, we would have they can't have a nuclear weapon.
That's all. They can't have nuclear weapons. It's too no nuclear
weapons. You can't have nuclear weapons. Okay. It goes on and
on like this for 16 minutes on and on like this. Okay. President
Trump has been absolutely 100% cons. I've become so anti-Semitic
now. It's insane. Rook, that's the wrong way to handle this.
Okay. No,
that's the wrong way to handle this. Okay. No, that's pretty.
We need We need a little more anti-semitism these days. Okay.
We need a little more. But it needs to be fake. Okay. It's fake.
Yeah. But I think that's what he's saying. We say I've become
so anti like he's saying, you know, I think that's got to be
tongue and cheek. It's fake to help them reaclimate into a normal
world. Okay. But it it can't be real. What is this? Sherry, what
is going on? Yeah. Like, do you feel too powerful, Quimman? What
are you doing? Yeah, he does. Oh, people like Ethan Cole are
too powerful. Okay. Oh, okay. Okay, that's a different thing.
That's the Rama's thing. Got it. You You are But you see others
who are too powerful, you can't even handle them. Got it. He
also thinks that he'll be fine even if they get knocked down
a peg cuz he is a supremacist. The problem said Aiden and Quean
are so arrogant in their Judaism, their loose background self-hating
because they think nothing can take them down and they can just
work against our own interests. Yep. Exactly. What is that Pokemon
where the only thing it can do is self-destruct in order to blow
up everything? Yeah, that's what's the other one called? What's
the little one called? Electro is the big one, right? Voltob.
Yeah, Voltob. Yeah. Insisted on this his entire political career.
All of it. And that's why, as we'll get to, all of the people
in the supposed MAGA coalition who are yelling at him about a
position that he has been taking consistently for 10 years without
a gap. Maybe you misinterpreted. Maybe you think you're the leaders
of MAGA. That guy is the creator of MAGA. That one, the president
of the United States. Here, I'm just going to read to you from
his 2015 golden escalator speech. Okay? Literally from the very
first moment he entered presidential politics as a Republican,
he was talking about this. quote, "We need to stop Iran from
developing nuclear weapons. Iran is going to take over the Middle
East." Okay. Iran is racing toward developing nuclear weapons.
He said all of those things in his opening speech when he came
down the golden escalator. Was he unclear? Did you miss the part
where he said it? Are you do do you have hearing problems? Do
you have a brain pro? He's been saying it consistently.
To all these people who are now muing and screaming and crying
because he's doing the thing he said he was going to do. welcomed
to President Trump who generally does the thing he says he is
going to do. So, President Trump then went to Truth Social and
reiterated this. He said, "Listen, America first means no nuclear
Iran. America first means many great things, including the fact
I'm sorry. No, it doesn't. That is not what the the issue is."
Okay, I'm sorry. If Iran obtains a nuclear weapon, America's
fate changes like 0% tomorrow. Okay? They don't have a nuclear
triad. They are zero threat to
All right, they are a threat to some people and it doesn't mean
a nuclear Iran is good, but America first does not mean a non-uclear
Iran. I'm sorry. It doesn't. That Iran cannot have a nuclear
weapon. You're confusing some other country's interest with your
own. Okay.
I I'm sorry.
That's what he's all about. That's Ben's job. Am I right? It
is. It is his job. Any clearer? Well, in case you were wondering,
he he actually tried to do it even more. Okay, Emanuel Mcronone
started trying to speak in President Trump's name, which is absurd,
suggesting that he was working on a ceasefire. So, first of all,
President Trump cannot stand Emanuel Mcronone, as we'll see a
little bit later on in the show. Neither, there's some good elements
to this. He covers the Dave Smith thing. You cover the Dave Smith
thing at all, Queen. No, I watched some of you covering Dave
Smith yesterday, though, whenever it was. I can't wait to see
Ben's going to be shaking. Can most people, as it turns out?
Oh, I can't imagine. Maybe there's a reason that he had to marry
a woman twice his age. In any case, he is not a popular man with
people who know him personally. Okay. Ben just going to sit here
at having to deal with Yeah. His wife's twice the age of him
because she found him when he was like 14. Ben K. She was his
teacher, wasn't she? Yeah. Well, she was a teacher in his school,
I think. I don't know if she was directly was it like might have
been I thought she was drama or something. Teachers. She might
have been like his drama like uh for some play like might have
been orchestrating that. I forget exactly what it was. Oh, also
dude, she was like a fizzed teacher and I remember Candace Owens
was like basically in in newspapers in France like oh she's trans.
She she was like the most attractive woman and then they like
showed pictures of her from around the time Emanuel Macccron
was in school with her and it's like oh no she looks like a female
gym like a female gym teacher. Okay, that's it's not great. It
was not Emanuel McRone. Her eyes rolled directly out of her head.
Anyway, President Trump was upset with Emanuel Mcronone. He tweeted,
quote, "Publicity seeking President Emanuel Mcronone of France.
Mistakenly said, I left the G7 summit in Canada to go back to
DC to work on a ceasefire between Israel and Iran." Wrong. He
has no idea why I'm now on my way to Washington, but it certainly
has nothing to do with the ceasefire. Much bigger than that.
Whether purposely or not, Emanuel always gets it wrong. Stay
tuned. I I do love the the forward pitch. It's in the industry.
That's what we call it when you have to pitch past a commercial.
I love it. He's great at this. He knows his industry. All righty.
Coming up, President Trump is ready to do something. What is
that something? We're not sure yet, but Tucker Carlson is good.
Good one, Ben. Good one, Ben. Companies inside his administration
who went leaking to people like Barack Ravid at Axio. Quite terrible
reporter who relies on dissension within the administration in
order to report things that end up very often nothing true. Is
there a bunch of people in the administration? Again, I have
suspicion as to which people who are leaking to Axio as per usual.
Always in the same direction. President Trump is going to pursue
negotiations. Dylan Burns tweeted out some of these as well.
In order to get elected, Barack Obama will start a war with Iran.
Barack Obama will attack Ron in order to get reelected. I predict
that President Obama will at some point attack Iran in order
to save face. I remember remember I that I predicted a long time
ago that President Obama will attack Iran because of his inability
to negotiate properly, not skilled. Properly hyphen not skilled.
Okay.
President Trump then went on to truth social. This would have
been at 5:20 this morning, Eastern time. Quote, I have not reached
out to Iran for peace talks in any way, shape, or form. This
is just more highly fabricated fake news. If they want to talk,
they know how to reach me. They should have taken a deal that
was on the table. Would have saved a lot of lives. Okay. Later
in the day, the president of the United States tweeted out a
message from Mike Huckabe, a text message from the ambassador
to Israel, Mike Huckabe. And here's what it says. Quote, "Mr.,
where are all the people who are like, dude, it's so up that
the US like gave Ukraine weapons and and like totally they they
totally provoked Russia. Russia is another country. We need to
respect other countries and like their space and their spheres
of influence." And then and then when it's like, "Oh, what about
Iran?" They're like, "No, no, no. You have to just every Iranian
like actually no Iranian sovereign Iranian sovereignty Iran.
Okay. Attack Iran. Always attack Iran. Iran's the the number
one enemy of the United States. Okay. Mr. President, God spared
you in Butler, Pennsylvania to be the most consequential president
in a century, maybe ever. The decisions on your shoulders. I
would not want to be made by anyone else. You have many voices
speaking to you, sir, but there is only one voice that matters.
His voice, meaning God's. I am your appointed servant in this
land. Mike Huckabe is just going to tell him to go with Israel.
Okay, listen. Listen to God. But also remember, God loves available
for you. But I do not try to get in your presence often because
I trust your instincts. No president in my lifetime has been
in a position like persuade you. Only Mike. Yeah, I encourage
you. I will hear from heaven and that voice is far more important
than mine or anyone else. You send me to Israel to be your eyes,
ears, and voice and to make sure our flag flies above our embassy.
My job is to be the last one to leave. I will not abandon this
post. Our flag will not come down. You did not seek this moment.
This moment is sought you. It is my honor to serve you. So President
Trump posted that except for Mike Kakabe, a pastor, politician,
ambassador, and a great person. And then later in the morning,
he tweeted out, quote, "We now have complete and total control
over the skies over Iran." Why is it we? What do you mean we?
What the is happening? Cuz he he made the same mistake. You about
to ask somebody about we? Yeah, you [__] United States,
Jerry. And I'm not talking about I'm not talking about Israel
having uh aerial dominance. Okay. What's going Did you Did you
just wake up yesterday?
You talk about me wondering why Trump's totally owned by Israel.
Yeah. I wonder why people are firing if America and Israel are
the same thing. The president of the United States shouldn't
do that. Has there been another president who's that shameless?
Like literally BB's about to message him and be like, "Bro, you
need to chill." Like
back off. Iran had good sky trackers and other defensive equipment
compared to Americanmade, conceived, and manufactured stuff.
Nobody does it better than the good old USA. Now notice the use
of the first person plural. All right. We now have complete and
total control over the skies of Iran, not Israel. We So all this
seems to imply that President Trump may be ready to simply put
an end to this conflict by No, it's not. When he uses it, Cherry,
it's not dropping a When when has Trump ever said we about anything?
He's like, I alone can get this COVID vaccine out. I alone got
this COVID vaccine out. He never uses we ever. This is the only
time he's ever shared credit for anything his entire life. Couple
they've got the PP tapes. That's how you know they got something.
That would be the easiest way to end the conflict. President
Trump knows that. That seems like a pretty easy lift for the
president of the United States. He also started removing troops
and personnel from American bases in eastern Syria presumably
to avoid any sort of blowback should he decide to make that call.
Now again, it's not clear that he is going to make that call
or which way he's going to go, but the president has the Iranians
right where he wants them. At this point, they have no hand to
play as the president likes to say. This becomes clear from another
Wall Street Journal piece that was reported this morning. Quote,
Ayat Kamei and his top advisers never expected Israel to launch
air strikes on the scale they have seen in recent days while
they were negotiating with the Americans. The foreign minister
told diplomats they'd been played by Trump and the US Middle
East special envoy Steve Whit into thinking negotiations would
prevent a strike. According to European and Arab officials, the
Iranians have said privately they could be open for resume negotiations
as long as Trump publicly says he doesn't support the Israeli
strikes. So what do they want? They want Trump to say that, "Oh,
no, no, I don't like the strikes." Trump's not going to do that.
Why would he possibly do that? They want the Iranians think they
can bully President Trump into saying that he disapproves the
Israeli strikes. With what with what leverage would they compel
the president of the United States, the most powerful person
on planet Earth with the unfettered capacity to fly over Iran
with anything he pleases up to and including a paraglider? Why?
What leverage do they think they have? This they're insane. They're
out of their minds. That's crazy. Apparently, the foreign minister
said a private message is give me two seconds. I just need to
charge my phone. I'll be right back. Not enough. The US government
needs to condemn the attack on nuclear facilities and explicitly
withdraw from this conflict to prove its good intentions. And
then he said that Iran would only accept a deal that allows it
to enrich uranium. This is Baghdad Bob kind of stuff. The foreign
minister is Tehran Tom. Apparently
that what what a hot take from the foreign minister. He's going
to bully the president of the United States into apologizing
for Israel's action in the Middle East. Good luck with that.
Meanwhile, the supposed conflict that is breaking out amongst
MAGA, it is not real. I'm just putting it out there. It's not
real. There are some voices that you hear that are very big on
X. some people who are in the media space who have yeah relatively
large audiences who are making the case that there's a gigantic
split in MAGA over whether the president decides to activate
the B2s to bomb Ford or or or not. And let's just be clear by
the polling data that is not true. This has been the poll is
totally manufactured Ben. Okay. When you say oh would you support
us like striking Iran if it was necessary? Yeah. Most people
are going to say well necessary? Sure. Yeah. I guess so. That's
what the question was. Do you support striking Iran if it's necessary
talking about that? That's so goofy from some some point. I understand
why
track this guy down in Grand Theft Auto now. I understand. I
get it. Uh-huh. And remains a French opinion. The president is
a peace through strength advocate. You think that the guy who
blew Kasm Salmani into little tiny pieces,
pieces so small that they could not put them back together again?
You think that that guy is a pacifist?
You think that the same Donald Trump who sent Tomahawk missiles
into Syria, that one's the pacifist? You think the president
who on Saturday had a gigantic military parade to show off our
hardware and praise the US Army's history? That guy's the P.
He doesn't sound like the kind of guy who, for example, thinks
that What up? What's up? Said no one showed up to the military
parade. Dude, nobody cared. Yeah, nobody cared. Did you see
like I literally there was more buzz about the protests than
there was about the parade. Well, that's why that's why nobody
showed up. Yeah, the no kings protests were just like that's
where literally everybody went. Maybe you could have gotten people
to show up, but like it was just a way better event. Yeah, unfortunately
they just protested Trump. I don't even think they protested
at the parade. I think they're just like way better event going
to the protest where they got shot by like rubber bullets and
just way funner over there. It is way better. Listen, yeah, it
is way better. That's just true. That's just objectively true.
Churchill was the bad guy of World War II. Doesn't sound like
the president of the United States. The president of the United
States. He doesn't sound like the kind of guy who thinks that
the bombing of Hiroshima and Nagasaki to end World War II. Dying
empire moment. Okay, it could be a dying empire moment for the
US right now. Okay, this could be a dying empire moment, but
also it's going to be like the the death of the empire in foundation.
Okay. Unfortunately, the US has like way more firepower and a
military that even if they weren't making things for like 10,
15, 20 years, they'd probably still be able to take on the rest
of the world. Okay. Like the technology is insane.
They're they're gapping everybody so badly, right? So, it I hope
it's not a falling empire because if for some reason they lose
economic dominance, I don't want to know how they'll try to get
it back. Be very scary. Was some sort of great moral blight on
the history of the United States. It doesn't sound like President
Trump. It sounds like other people in the supposed MAGA movement,
people who wish to grab control of that MAGA movement, pretend
that they are the substitute leaders of that MAGA movement, that
actually it's their movement independent of President Trump.
But that doesn't sound very much like President Trump to me.
Well, obviously one of those people
say Nick. I think it's I think it's more like the Tucker, Alex
Jones. I think it's like a lot of the other media personalities.
He might I don't think I've ever I've never heard one of them
claim that like the MAGA movement is theirs or they're the the
real leader or anything like that, but I've heard Fuentes say
basically that like a hundred times that we're the MAGA movement.
The MAG movement is ours. We you know Bannon could talk about
Bannon. I don't know what Bannon said recently, so I've got no
idea. Bannon's super against this. Bannon is losing his
possibly about Bannon then. Yeah, Bannon could be it for sure.
Yeah, that is I do want to check this out because I had a tweet
about it in my docket. It's just like um yeah, Steve Bannon just
sounded the alarm the next 200 days could decide the fate of
the American republic.
Jeez. What about the other old white guy Roger
Stone? No, Roger Stone is not a serious They don't Roger Stone's
not taken seriously for any of his like geopolitical views. He's
just good.
Yeah, cuz he got Nixon's face tattoo on his back. Who could take
him serious after that? Uh true. Yes. Yeah. face on your back.
It is weird, isn't it? I don't know when this interview is done.
I do want to watch it though at some point. I'll have to watch
this one and the whole Ted Cruz one. I'll probably watch this
one first. I don't really care about Ted Cruz's opinions. So,
over the course of the last 48 hours, he has continued to up
the ante. So, last week he put out, of course, a newsletter in
which he suggested that the president had betrayed MAGA and America
first. And President Trump responded by saying he made MAGA in
America first. Of course, is true. And then, oh, what's up, Wes?
How's it going? And yesterday, Tucker spun off while doing an
interview with Steve Bannon, who seems to be taking a similar
position, talking about how this could end Trump's presidency.
By what stretch of the You could maybe argue he doesn't mean
Bannon if he was going to like talk about somebody saying that
and then reference him later, like then he'd just say it by name.
Maybe. So, maybe Fuentes. One second. I'm just reconnecting my
headphones. Oh, no. Wait, I did I miss Jerry saying something
there? I heard a I heard a sound. Nope. Okay. He's taking a similar
position talking about how this could end Trump's presidency
by what stretch of the imagination? Although for some reason
Todd Bronson just spam KKW in chat. So seriously,
a full-scale invasion and occupation of Iran would end his presidency.
Fortunately, literally no one alive is talking about that because
that would be crazy. But here is Tucker Carlson again going after
the president on this.
I actually really love Trump. I think he's a deeply humane, kind
person.
And I am saying this because I I'm really afraid that my country
is going to be further weakened by this. I think we're going
to see the end of American empire. Obviously, uh other nations
would like to see that and this is a perfect way to scuttle the
US America on the shores of Iran. But it's also going to end,
I believe, Trump's presidency and effectively end it. Okay. So,
it's going to effectively end Trump's presidency. It's going
to it's going to end America and American empire. I thought he
doesn't like American Empire, first of all. So, what is he so
worried about? He doesn't like America's role in the world. Also,
you know, I'm going to take it with a grain of salt when he says
that he loves the president of the United States since in 2020
it was uncovered in that lawsuit in which Dominion Voting Systems
filed lawsuit against Fox News that he would Yeah. Trump's always
Trump's always advertised himself as anti-war. I do think if
you could give people if you could somehow inject like the facts
of the matter into people's heads all of MAG you can't do that
but all of MAGA if they knew like what the
what the what would you call it the um precipitating factors
were for Israel striking Iran I think none of them would support
war with Iran like US involvement I mean okay but like that's
90% of Trump policies right if you could inject all relevant
facts in someone's head
but I'm saying I'm saying like given their positions uh they
they just wouldn't want a war with this like they could maybe
be convinced like oh well Iran was you know they tried to Trump
and they've they could put nukes that could hit the United States
or something they they might have ICBM like I you actually can't
even make that like there's just no argument for Iran being a
threat to the US in any way. So yeah was texting people saying
that he quote unquote passionately hated Donald Trump in 2020.
So I'm not sure whether he passionately loves Donald Trump or
he passionately hates Donald Trump. Go ahead. Maybe this is my
ignorance, but the idea that there is a country that is consistently
trying to the person that's running
my country, how is that not a threat to my country? Oh, sure.
You could say that. I don't know how much we are we not constantly
using our resources to mitigate that.
It has nothing to do with our nuclear sites, right? I mean, yeah.
So, not this not to do with nuclear or anything, but you would
still consider them a threat to the country. Sure. If he is our
president, which is not a significant threat though, I think
really like it's it's like just not Well, I couldn't know how
significant. US has never gone to war with them either. Well,
and I can't know how significant, right? How legit are the conspiracy
theories about that Las Vegas shooting being related to the Saudis?
I don't know. I Some new stuff just got released about that.
And yeah, I think the body cam footage got released or some [__]
We figured that out. There was a body cam that was they claimed
just deleted for ages or it wasn't it didn't exist but then they
reported was deleted and then it wasn't deleted and they just
released it. I have not looked into it at all but um it I can't
imagine it shows something than what was like different than
what was recorded where like this guy just had like a guns and
like people had come into that room. I think what was the conspiracy
that it was like people he was like most of the comments I saw
were just saying how inept and the cops at Shob were basically.
Yeah. Sorry, I'm trying to think of the answer to Cherry's question
that like if they're if Iran's trying to like realistically I
wonder how serious that is and how much every country is trying
to like the US president in some way at like a low grade. to
just like put a couple random people there who like K if you
could get it done. I like I actually have no idea cuz apparently
didn't Obama have like a hundred or more like credible threats
to his life that they actually had to intervene on when he was
president like like apparently the US president is the target
of assassinations just pretty consistently. So I don't know.
Yeah, but I feel like this was with Iran. Well, I thought it
was bizarre because I don't think we'd ever been told what country
is trying to kill our president before. I want you to think about
why that might be why that why why that information might have
come out with Iran specifically in this case. Yeah, I can understand
that. Yeah, it's I don't know. But the thing is then at that
point we have to start being suspicious all the way when that
started happening. Why did they leak that information? Um, I
guarantee you that a lot of people around Trump like Pel Gabbert
probably would have said that's fake and they're only saying
that because they want us to go to war with Iran because that's
usually the response to those kinds of things. Well, it has successfully
um affected my judgment, I guess. Well, I mean, yeah, it's hard
to know cuz another similar thing happened just yesterday that
was brought up in the Dave Smith interview with Crystal and Cigar.
They um they brought up how somebody had reported it was like
leaked to them that there was like an operational window where
Israel could have assassinated Kumani, the the grand what do
you call it? The supreme leader of Iran, right? And Crystal,
which like I kind of laugh, but it's it's like smart. Yeah, you
can't really take that seriously.
Like why would why would that ever become information? Like you
say that and that in and of itself is a move to ever leak that
to the press, right? That is a move. You're trying to evaluate
some response from Iran based on that information. See if they'll
bite or do something, right? It's not really um Supreme Leader.
You can call him the Ayatollah. You can call him the Supreme
Leader. Doesn't matter. They call him Supreme Leader Kamei, right?
I think so. I understand that he's also the Ayatollah though.
But yeah, I don't know. There's like when intelligence leaks
like that happen that like give things away. I find countries
just don't do it that much. They don't give things like that
away unless there's a reason. Anyway, continue on with Benny
Boy here. whether he believes that Donald Trump has betrayed
the MAGA movement or what he believes President Trump has betrayed
about the MAGA movement. Suffice it to say, President Trump was
unhappy with this. And President Trump labeled Tucker Carlson
kooky yesterday. He put out a statement on Truth Social
in which he said, "Someone please explain to kooky Tucker Carlson
that Iran can never have a nuclear weapon." So, President Trump
calls Tucker Carlson cookie Tucker, which again I think is a
very, very good descriptor of Tucker Carlson. Okay, this is crazy.
Yes, my president is calling somebody kooky. Ben Shapiro though
is reporting on somebody someone being called kooky.
This is insane. People are like, "Oh, you know, Twitch politics
is so ineffective. It doesn't get anything done." And if like
people just talking and then you go and look at the president,
he's like, "Yeah, Tucker Carlson's a kooky guy." Somebody explained
to Cookie Tucker Carlson that Iran cannot have a nuclear weapon.
Okay, this just in. Trump has now called Tucker Carlson cookie.
Yeah, it's that that's where this is the world we live in. We're
all just in different layers of high school, Sherry. Okay, you're
in high school forever. You never escape. It's just different
layers of high school. High high stakes high school. Okay, let's
just say that he has pushed a bunch of theories that are specious
in the extreme, unbased in evidence or reason. And you can enjoy
to your heart's content. It is a free country. Suffice it to
say, I do not find that his takes are rooted in reality, rooted
in rationality
at this point. And President Trump, of course, sounding off about
this because Tucker is the leader of an entire new wing of MAGA.
It's not very large, but it is very loud, suggesting that the
president is not in control of the movement that he created.
That of course includes representative Marjgerie. Oh,
okay. He was literally talking about Tucker earlier, right? This
is the exact quote. the lady up.
She of the less than average IQ.
She put out a statement talking about how much she loves Tucker
Carlson. He's one of her favorite people. That's fine. That's
fine. He unapologetically believes the same things I do, says
Marjorie Taylor Green. That if we don't fight for our own country
and our own people, then we will no long Marjgery Marjgery Taylor
[__] the the woman possessing not a very high IQ
longer have a country for our children and our grandchildren.
Okay, we thank you for that meaningless statement. I think we
all agree with that. and foreign wars intervention, regime change,
put America last, innocent people are making us broke and will
ultimately lead to our destruction. Well, I mean this, let me
tell you, Marjorie, if this was a civilized country, you'd be
turning my lights on and off on Sundays. Okay, those aren't be
happy. All the same thing. Wars, intervention, and regime change
like every intervention like that that that made America broke
and led to our destruction. They said that's not kooky. That's
what a millions of Americans voted for. It's what we believe
is America. Who gives a when Marjorie Taylor Green believes is
America first compared to D deep lore joke? I called her Marjgery
Taylor [__] and said she'd be turning the lights
on and off on Sundays. How is that deep lore? That's not even
confusing. That's like a very on the surface joke. Donald J.
Trump again. I have my disagreements with President. That's anti-semitism,
right? I feel like those jokes go over my head. It's really hard
to understand them. More likeism.
Yeah, it's not necessarily anti-semitism. It's like a fun joke.
It's a It's just a fun joke. So, um it translates some people
who are like Orthodox Jew or if they're more strict in their
observations, they know that you're not supposed to do work on
Shabas, which is Sundays, okay? And some interpret using electricity
at all as doing work. And so, they don't they don't and especially
turning on and off electricity is somehow like doing work. So
what they'll do is they'll hire a shabascoy, somebody who is
not an actual
or they'll have a friend who will come do it who will be able
to turn on their electronics or their oven for them because they
observing their religious, you know, duties don't want to do
that. And so sometimes yeah, sometimes if somebody's like subservient
to people, you might call them a shabasoy is like a insult you
can use for them. Uh that is kind of anti-semitic potentially,
but that was the whole joke about turning the lights on and off
on Sunday. See you really anti-Semitic to be honest. I don't
think that's anti-Semitic at all. Someone shy. If they're if
they're totally shilling for or is calling someone shy, I don't
think it's particularly anti-semitic. I It's anti in the way
that if you say about someone shilling for Israel, it's anti-mitic
in the way that conflating anti-ionism, anti-semitism is anti-semitic.
You know, it is, but I'm still going to leave that, you know,
I I'll I'll make the joke, but uh I'll always say it's anti-semitic
cuz I don't have the ethnic past, okay? I can't just go, "Oh,
so I'm one of you guys." Tell Cherry about the [__]
cast system in Manhattan. I don't know what you're talking about.
Bravo. That weird.
Are those the tunnels? Wait, I know about the [__]
cast system. JTO,
I don't I literally don't know. Why is J afraid to address the
Manhattan [__] cast system? Wait, wait, that's one
I don't know. Hold on. I know a lot of them. That feels weird
that I don't know that one. Is that one you talk about? Google
it now. Google it. Evil Johnny Bravo. Is that the one where they
jump down the tunnels with the mattresses? Was she? No. No. No,
it's not. That's not it. Would you look at the time? It is 2
minutes until the end of the stream. It mean we do not have enough
time to address whatever this is. Uhoh.
Uh-oh, guys. Oh boy. Um, let me let me look that up. I'll never
forget I'll never forget when I went to the Bronx Zoo in New
York and I it blew my mind.
The in New York, they love the zoo. They're there like in numbers,
in droves.
The a majority of the Bronx Zoo is just people walking around
and they were all up in their garb. Yeah, they have everything.
Yeah, that's not crazy, but the curl the curls are out in the
front. Hold on. I just I just for some reason the way you talk
the way you just said this made me think of this said what? And
I have to watch this clip now. Unfortunately, Maxmith, thank
you for the sub. Appreciate it, buddy. I don't think I'm adding
more time to the stream right now. So, don't try to get there
on the goals, guys. Okay. I'm We just did a long stream. I'll
be crying if I look like that, too, bro. That'sed up what they
be doing to y'all. I ain't even gonna hold you. Hold on. Hold
on. Yeah, I got to watch this. But that broke the video, bro.
I'll be crying if I look like that, too, bro. That's up what
they be doing to y'all. I ain't even going to hold you, bro.
I be saying that's up. Like, bro, you probably had the full wash
and set. Your [__] be fire probably if they ain't
cut your bro. It's your life.
It's so weird. But Maxmith, thank you for another gifted sub.
240 subs. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. I don't know why I said thank you so many times. All
right, guys. That is it for the stream. Um I can I might continue
some of this Israel stuff tomorrow with the I might keep going
with the Ben video. I might watch it offline by myself. If there's
a world war, I don't think you get to control whether or not
you're governing Israel. We link that. Wait, evil giant bravo.
You never seen that video before? I thought people got really
mad at that black man for doing that. I don't think this is the
original video either. That guy [__] talking [__]
I bet he doesn't even have waves. All right. Okay. Also,
um we're going to be pushing the streams like later and longer.
Okay. We're going to be streaming a lot. We need to make up for
lost time. Okay. We've had a lazy two weeks here and now we have
to make it so we get, you know, 240ish hours in the month of
June. So, we will be here a lot. We'll be here a lot all the
time. Okay. Tons of streaming time. Raid somebody. I'm thinking
about going on vacation again. Cherry's thinking about going
on vacation. When I said we, I meant I I will be here all the
time forever and ever and ever and ever.
Okay. Raid somebody. I can raid resi. I raided um I raided the
past two days. So, I'll just raid Resi. I I do love Rei. Guys,
just know that Rei is live. Okay, if you want to opt to go watch
Rei, Rei is live right now. Now he's covering stuff, but I'm
going to raid resi just cuz I haven't raided anybody else. Although
the last time I raided resi, he eventually raided Tom. Uh so
you don't get to decide who people are friends with. Ew. I don't.
But I can encourage better friendships. Guys, have a good time.
Enjoy watching relevant and I will see you guys tomorrow. Okay,
thanks for the stream. W stream. Be back later. Bye.